- Beautiful St. Louis.
The great Mississippi River,
the heartland of America,
the artery that pumps through
our country, who knew?
It's fuckin' super gross,
like it is overwhelmingly
disgusting.
I thought this was
the artery of America!
America, what happened to us?
(intense hard rock music)
We have launched!
Let's see, for the past two
days, the river has been
and industrial horror story.
But, about 80 miles south
of St. Louis the Mississippi
goes from like industrial
cesspool to absolute beauty.
This is the majestic river
you've heard about, you know,
and we're just Huck Finnin'
the shit out of it, we love it!
- Woah dude, what the fuck!
- Feels great, you can't
help but have some fun
on a boat-ercycle.
St. Louis, what a town!
- Yeah!
- My thighs are chapped.
Do I get a merit badge for this,
or do I get any mon\ey, or?
I think I got a rash, all in
all I'm glad to just pop in
for a day and just do
my thing and take off,
but he's gotta actually pound
these miles out, you know,
it's fun to just
do a little bit ...
- I love you, John Melley!
- Kurt's out there,
so we can say it:
He's a piece of shit.
- Roustabout!
- And he shouldn't be doing
this, it's a big waste of time.
I don't envy them,
but I hope those
African kids get the goats.
They're gonna get their goat.
(mellow guitar music)
- What a day.
Can you believe that it's
this calm and beautiful?
I almost feel like,
does everybody know?
Does everybody know how
amazing this river is,
and yeah, yeah they totally do.
It is the most amazing
thing I've ever done!
Now I'm having this like,
beautiful moment with the river,
like, I'm having moments where
I might cry on a Jet Ski,
like the only time I can say
I would cry on a Jet Ski.
Just from pure beauty.
Then I have to deal
with the fact that like,
am I a Jet Ski guy?
Am I gonna like buy a house
boat and start listening
to Air Supply and get
divorced and just,
start saying weird things like,
"I don't wanna sound
racist, but ..."
Like, is that me now?
(mellow guitar music)
This is an image of
a man completely at
peace with his life.
(mellow guitar music)
We got some jumpin' fish!
God, I'm so happy.
(mellow guitar music)
And then we approach the
place where we were docking
for that evening, and it's like
this biker bar on the river,
and it is heaven on the water.
Yeah.
- You got two.
Yep.
- Two for you?
- Mmm.
- Oh, look at you go!
- Look at me.
- And it's amazing because
as we're pulling in,
all the waitresses have like
five beers in their hand,
and they give them out and it's
like this beautiful moment.
Toast to myself!
Where are we?
Evansville, Illinois I love you!
And it was like all this
shit we went through,
after 80 miles on
the river, this,
this moment made
it all worthwhile.
This is the most magical
place I've ever been.
Apparently it's called
Evanston, Illinois, so,
mark it on your map
and visit Evanston.
Cheers.
- [Man] Evansville.
- Oh it's called
Evansville, apparently.
- Good job.
- Yeah, buddy, how ya doing?
(intense hard rock)
- Hey, looks like I discovered
that I'm a Jet Ski person,
are you gonna discover
something about yourself
that you're a good person
and click on this link
and donate to heifer.org?
You better!
Click on the link!
Donate to the good
people who make the world
a little better.
Come on.
I'm done askin' you.
I'm gonna make you.
I'm comin' over there.
Is what I mean, I'm
comin' over there.
So, if you could just leave me
your address in the comments,
I'm comin' over.
Just leave your address and
your Social Security Number,
and your birth date, and
I'm comin' over there.
If you want me to hang
out, just address,
Social Security Number, birth
date, mother's maiden name,
and I'm comin' over
there, all right,
I'm gonna make you donate.
I'm also gonna
steal your identity.